first of all Angela you look great and
ninety-day fans have been saying this
online everyone is commenting on your
weight loss was this something
intentional for you to lose weight you
know I go up and down with my way when
I'm happy I lose I'm you know I'm uh I
guess emotional eater I love my cake so
I stay away from cakes when I'm when I'm
happy then I'm like in between I like in
do i okay so what something that you did
on purpose because we saw you and Skylar
in the premiere at a twerk class where
you are looking good how does Michael
feel about it you know obviously Michael
just wants me to meet him me like he
doesn't want me to lose weight
I've smooth way but you know being an
owner I want to feel good about
ourselves so I can make myself feel good
when I'm around you in public
we did for the US right right well
you've been open about you know using
Botox in the past fans have also been
admiring how youthful you look it's a
just Botox oh do you have a new secret
now just Botox and fillers you know I do
want to probably do other things like
maybe surgical I have it Michael doesn't
know about it because he's against all
that stuff but on the ankle and that's
hereditary and Botox and only do so much
that's got to go you know I mean I can
lose weight and still be there my mom
and my dad have it so good about it the
chin is that the only thing that you
want is it something more you want to
get there I want to get a foot I'm gonna
bite so are you gonna get a Brazilian
butt lift or it's gonna be like a fat
transfer you know I'm just learning
about it so um I don't know I don't
really know what I'm doing but I say
bring it on yes so you're ready you're
not nervous about it at all no not at
all anything to make me feel calm which
I'm already competent person anyway we
were there I'm fatter skinnier year old
looking but uh you
every woman wants to feel beautiful with
their making it and you know who him
being younger he just took never make me
feel old or feel like I look old but you
know there's always a mirror then Angela
the way were you fine I get what you're
saying but looking at you you know you
and Michael together it's like we we
like you guys you can saying we admire
you two together so I don't think
anyone's looking like oh my god like
we're real how do you feel when the fans
compare you to Lisa
you and Michael situation so Lisa knows
me no comparison I'd like to say about
that there's only one Angela
[Music]